45th Annual Cancer Control Society Convention Labor Day Week in 2017 with the lovely Hilton
Hotel in Glendale, California. We're very, very happy to have you here. And our next
speaker, a chiropractor by training, education, and course experience. And he's going to
talk to us about treating the cause of the disease rather than just treating the disease
itself. Dr. Kevin Connors has, not just like share a little personal thing, has five children.
And in the biographies it mentions 12 grandchildren. That's two more than my wife and I have. And
then he mentioned to me just before that since our programs were printed, he has three more
grandchildren. So he has a total of 15. But he is here to talk to us about stop fighting
cancer and start treating the cause. Dr. Connors, very happy to have you here.
Thank you. All right. Start treating the cause. Everybody wants to treat the cause. That's
a big, that's a big thing for me at our office. The side that was just up there was a book
that I wrote. I can't remember what I wrote it probably about seven, eight years ago. And
I've updated it a couple of times. And share a little bit why I titled it that way. Because
when I started seeing patients that had cancer was about 18 years ago. I graduated as a chiropractor.
Actually graduated as a kinesiologist chiropractor. So I did a lot of what would be known as functional
medicine back in 1986. And so a lot of people with adrenal issues and hormone issues and
such that I was always interested in frequency technology. I didn't really know then why I was
interested in it. But I do know. And I studied rife's work and he worked on light frequencies
and it was just drawn to it. And I do know that it was just God that was drawing me to it. And I
actually picked out the rife machine that I wanted to have in my office and I actually called
the company. And I was about that close to ordering one probably a dozen times and had the picture
of it up on my desk ahead of my desk. But I'm going to say I was a chiropractor. I don't treat
cancer patients. Why was this hunger in my heart for this? Well, I had a very big chiropractic
practice. And it was being blasted a lot of ways. But I just felt empty in a lot of ways. And I
think it was 1997 or 1992. I saw my practice because I just knew God was leading me in a different
direction. We ended up spending some time in trading and went and became full-time missionaries
down in Multiray, Mexico. And I taught. And a Bible school down there. And we worked in an orphanage
down there. And really believed that that's what God wanted us to do. And I thought, well, maybe
he trained me to be a chiropractor and trained me in natural medicine to be able to help unfortunate
people down there. And we did wonderful work. And God blessed it. But I still felt like there was just
this aching urge that that wasn't what we were supposed to do. I do know that God sometimes takes
things away from you when it becomes an idol in your heart. And I do believe that I wanted to be
a chiropractor when I was in junior and high school when I got help by a chiropractor. And it
had become kind of an idol in my life. So I think that looking back at it now, God kind of took that
away from me for a purpose to be able to teach me and show me things. Well, he did teach me and show
me things. He gave me back a practice in the late 90s. But then he revealed to me that it wasn't
going to be a chiropractic practice. One of my patients who was a chiropractic patient came to me
and said, I have to talk to you right now. And she was normally this jovial, bubbly 68-year-old woman.
And she was just looked terrified. So I brought her into the back office and said, what's wrong,
char? And she said, I found out I have breast cancer in both breasts. And it's tripled
negative. They said it's the worst you could get. And they said, if I don't do chemo and radiation,
I have three months to live. And I kind of stood there very wide. I'm wondering why she's telling me this
because I'm a chiropractor. And she said, well, no, you don't understand. I nursed my friend through
the chemo. And she died of the chemo my best friend five months ago. I'm not doing that. If you can't
help me, well, then I'm just ready to die. And it's not very often in my life that I hear these aha
moments. But that was one of them where I really felt the Holy Spirit just say, it's time. And I do
exactly what he was talking about. And I said, char, don't even ask me what it is. I'm going to go order
or write out, have a second day, next day aired to me. And I want you to come in and do this.
And it was miraculous. That was my beginning. It was my lesson. And it was hers too. She lived in
another 15 years and died of a heart attack. Then God slowly brought another cancer patient,
another cancer patient, another cancer patient. I thought, oh, my goodness, what is going on here?
And I got a little worried as I was studying and studying and studying all this stuff that you're
learning here on what to do to help cancer patients. Because I'm a little obsessive compulsive when
it comes to that. And, but I felt like, what if I miss something? So I went and got a degree in
different alternative medicine, functional medicine degrees. I got a fellowship in functional medicine
into aging medicine and in integrative cancer therapy and botanical medicine. And now genetics. And
that's kind of been my lifelong quest, just to constantly look at what the cause is. Because that's
one thing that God put my heart for a very beginning, is that it's not about the diagnosis. To
me, a diagnosis is a lack name for a collection of symptoms. It's about what's the cause of that?
So we don't want to label somebody with putting a stamp on them with a lack name that gives
them a disease. Besides, I don't want to ever label a person that they own that disease.
We want to find out what the cause of this is that the disease itself is something going
out of the body that's not supposed to be going out of the body. And there's a reason why. The other
thing that I noticed with cancer patients is that this whole anger issue, and I'm sorry if you're
there because I know that that's stages that we go through when we get the big diagnosis of cancer,
we go through anger and depression and upsetness. And that's normal and that's healthy. But I don't
think it's valuable to live there. So the whole idea of you see on the internet now,
F cancer and all this stuff, it's like, I understand where people are coming from. They're upset that
they have this diagnosis or they upset that that cancer seems to be taking their loved ones lives.
But I don't think it's healthy for the patient to stay there. So my philosophy with my patients is to
stop fighting cancer and look at it in a different perspective. It's there for a reason.
Maybe it's because of my exposure to toxins. Maybe it's because of my bad relationships that I had.
There's multiple reasons why cancer is there. Let's discover why and let's work on that.
I think it's a healthier relationship to be in with whatever you got going on because this cancer
that's growing inside of me is an aberrant process that I need help with. And I believe that we serve
a sovereign God and he knows what he's doing. And he didn't allow this to happen in my life. And yes,
maybe it's a curse, maybe it's a demonic, maybe it's whatever. But whatever else it is, it's something
for me to learn from and to grow through and to discover why it's there and to start working
at changing that. So that's why I titled my book Stop Fighting Cancer. And let's start looking
at the cause. I have several other books out on cancer. I'm really big into cancer genetics. And
we're going to talk a little bit about that here today. Hopefully we'll have time. And I treat
Lyme patients in my office. So I have three or four Lyme books that I've written and much other stuff.
Also, just so you know, if you do have any interest in my books, I only brought one I could carry
in my bag here. I don't sell a ton of books though. They're all on Amazon because I give them away
free on my website. So you can go on the Conner's Clinic dot com website and download them all for free
if you want to. If you do download our books for free, you'll get out our cancer newsletter or
our Lyme newsletter, depending on books you download. And nowhere am I ever selling anything or anything
like that. My belief is that God gives me information and I have to give it away. So I like to teach
and when they said I only had 25 minutes, I thought what? All right, so we got to get going. All right,
so next slide. I talk about four pillars to deal with cancer. So that's our approach that God
kind of gave me years ago. These four major pillars. And then I go off of that. These four pillars
the healing. The first pillar is finding the cause. I always thought it was weird that
this study cancer in pathological reports and they could do a smear of a of stomach cancer cells
post-mortem after a person died and realized that if you look up in the World Health Organization,
that the number one cause of stomach cancer worldwide is H. Pylora infection. And it's like good
to say, even knowing that information has anyone gone the conventional method of treating cancer
with stomach cancer and have the oncologist say, boy, we should treat H. Pylora in you because that's
the number one cause of stomach cancer worldwide. I have not yet had anybody tell me that that had
stomach cancer. And it's like, why? They just ignore it. Well, I know why. They don't have a drug for
all these different things. So no sense looking for it. I think that's ridiculous. So in all our patients,
we check for the cause. So the cause of the cancer is that if I find out the cause of the cancer,
you have stomach cancer is H. Pylora. And we treat the H. Pylora. That necessarily won't necessarily
take care of the existing cancer itself. We still have to work on the cancer. Somebody's cell
photos up here going up, but we'll just take them. I should have answered it and started talking.
Better. So treating the cause of the cancer is primary. Even though that's not going to in my mind
necessarily take the cancer away, it's going to help prevent metastasis. It can help prevent the growth of
circulating tumor cells taking up home and raising a family somewhere else. So that's piece number
one. Piece number two is proper personalized nutrition. Now you see a whole bunch of boosts out here,
whole bunch of information about what to do specifically for cancer. And my philosophy is a
little bit different than other people's philosophy in treated cancer. I believe less is more. I don't
believe hitting everything all at once. And I think if that's what you do, that's fine. But that's not
what I do with our patients. So with our patients, I want to be as specific as possible. So if you,
my my understanding of physiology is the more things that you take in and absorb. Let's say I
going to take every supplement there is because I heard this was good. And Ellen said this helped her
brother's cancer. And this guy at church said his sister's friends uncle got cured of cancer using
this product. So I'm going to use these products. And if we take too many things and our body cannot
use those, our liver has to detoxify that. So when we overload our liver detox pathways,
that can be a bad thing. So in my practice, I want to be as specific as possible. So we test
each person individually. Many times they'll get people calling and say, what's your protocol for
prostate cancer? I don't have a protocol for prostate cancer. Everybody's different. I could have
two twin sisters with left breast cancer, the exact same cancer they got at the same day and they
could have a completely different protocol after we test them. Because they could have a different
cause and even if they have the same cause, what's going to work on one person that's going to work on
the other person? So we do that. We do very specific testing in our office. So I have just about every
product that's out there and a whole lot more on my shelves, but we test everybody individually.
That's just my belief. So personalized nutrition is important for us. Not only is nutrition. So when
I talk about personalized nutrition, it's what are we going to take from a nutraceutical standpoint to
help kill the cancer? What nutraceutical is it going to be, you know, what specific nutrient is
going to be the best thing that's going to be for that person to kill the cancer? The other thing
about personalized nutrition is diet. And I'll talk about this in a later slide, but I'm going to
touch on it now because I'm thinking about it is that there's what diet does a cancer patient do?
Oh, the main range right now is a ketogenic diet. Everybody should go on a ketogenic diet.
I know, not, no, they shouldn't. So well, they should go on a, you know, more of a
gertian type diet where they're low, low protein and they're juicing. Everybody should be juicing.
Everybody that has cancer should be juicing. Well, juicing and ketogenic diet do not go together.
Okay? So a ketogenic diet is severely limiting your glucose intake in every way, shape and form.
You can't even have root vegetables in a ketogenic diet because we're trying to get your body
to start functioning off of ketones so that glycolysis is impaired. So when you take in glucose,
it goes through glycolysis and it, it, it can feed cancer through lactic acid because some cancers
can feed off of lactic acid. Other cancers can feed off of glutamide and methydine. Those are amino
acids. Oh, well, a ketogenic diet. You're eating lots of meat, lots of protein, lots of fat. Wait a
second. That's very high in glutamine and methydine. Whoa, totally opposite diets. What's right for me?
Which one should I do? So in our office, we do genetic testing. That's actually the fourth pillar.
I'm getting ahead of myself, but that's really important because it depends upon your genes. They give
us clues on what is the metabolic pathway your cancer is going to feed off of. So if I have specific
genetic defects on certain genes that's going to allow excess methydine, excess glutamine,
then cancer has got a fuel source. And really, if you're really going to quote unquote fight cancer,
you have to do so like a military spirit and go, what's the best way to win this battle? Let's cut
off the supply lines and that's what we have to do with diet. So what are that persons? What is that
person's main supply line? Is it glutamine? Is it methydine? Is it glucose through lactic acid
through glycolysis? There's a way to know that and your genes give us lots of clues. So we do
genetic testing on everybody. So that's really, really important to me because you can be on this textbook
perfect diet because I read about this or my friend told me their cancer got cured by a ketogenic
diet and you're actually feeding the cancer with excess glutamine and methydine. So people ask me all
this, you got to look at the bads and you got to be really careful because what a fad might be,
it might be good for a certain person that got healed with, you know, got issues or whatever issues
and then they jump on that bandwagon and think that it's fit for everyone and we're all individuals.
Every single person is different and if you don't treat people differently,
and test them differently so to find out what's going to be specific for them,
I think we miss things. So we have a real good success right in our office and I think partly it's
due to this. So we have to be as specific as possible. We use frequency healing in my office. I told
you my story about my first cancer patient ever who we use the rife technology. We use rife
technology for all our cancer patients but it's how you program that rife that makes a difference.
So if you don't know what rife is, that's all due to you. I have a bunch of videos on our website
and our website is free to use so I think I have over 200 videos on our website. You'll get sick
a listen to me. I can't even listen to me but I like to teach anything I learned new. I want to
put it out there because this shouldn't be just for doctors. This should be for patients to learn
this stuff. So we use frequency technology. We use sound frequency and light frequency. Light
frequency is with the rife machine. Our cancer patients, all of them go home with a rife machine
that's programmed to them and they use it at night while they sleep because my philosophy and cancer
is that I don't want my patients making an idol out of treating their cancer.
So I don't want my patients going home and spending all they love juicing, doing this, thinking
what they're going to take, thinking what they're going to do, thinking what they're going to do.
They're no good to anybody. If I had to do that, I think I'd just rather not die and go back home
to heaven because if I can't be used to people here on earth than what sense is it? And I don't want
them to be so consumed with treating their cancer that they're no earthly good. So most of our treatment
is done at night. All of our patients are sleeping with the rife. We do that. My wife had melanoma
going on five years ago in this coming October and she went through the same processes. All my
patients do. We run a rife every single night. I flip open the computer, boot up their program,
hit the program that I made for my wife and I, hit run, close the computer, the bulbs in bed with us.
And that's to do norm for my patients. Might as well get treated. You got to sleep any home,
might as well get treated. And then you can live during the day. And again, because we use specific
nutrition, you're not taking 40 different supplements, you're not taking three or four. And then we do
genetic testing. So genetic testing is really important to me because it tells us an enormous
amount of information about that patient. So we test right now about 9,000 genes.
And we really look at about 2,000 of them real closely. And I probably have two dozen videos
at our website about genetic testing. If you watch just the one where I go over, somebody's genes
sexually over a year old, they have to update it. Because it takes about two hours or so to go over
somebody's genes at least. That's just the main piece that we go over. But you can tell the three
major diet types. So I told you the two, a ketogenic diet on one side, a low protein diet,
low glutamate, low botaniety diet on the other side. And then the middle diet is a mixed diet. So
before I have a patient's genetics back, which when they come to me, usually I don't have their
genes back yet. Most of them haven't run a complete 23 and me panel yet. Before we have that
back, we put people on a mixed diet, which is low glutamate, low botaniety, low sugar. But they are
getting, you know, they're not getting like a low sugar diet, like a ketogenic. And they're not
getting a low glutamate, low botaniety, like a full low protein diet. But it's a mixed. So about a
third of our patients are staying on that because their genes don't give us clues that it's fed
mainly by that pathway or not. Because some cancers, though sugar is bad for everybody, some cancers
aren't specifically fed through dietary, they're diet. They're just not. Some are specifically fed
through botaniety, including some are specifically fed through glycolysis. So we want to find out what
that is with that patient. And we have to look at detox pathways. Believe it or not, there's a lot
of people that get cancer. When you talk about causes, what is the cause of cancer? Somebody
wrote about fungus is the cause of all cancer. I don't believe that's true. There is about as many
different causes of cancer or there are things in our environment. So if I have defects that I just
put two little pieces of the detox pathway genetics up here. There's like pages of them. We have to
look at all those detox pathways with like this person on their pond one pathway where that's the
pathway that you detoxify pesticides and sector signs, large chemicals and vaccinations. If I have
defects on that pathway and I am exposed to those things, I can't get them out of my body very well.
So then they settle in cells. And then they settle in cells and they can interrupt the cell replication
cycle. And that's called cancer. So knowing that is kind of important. Should anybody be using
pesticides and sector signs and getting vaccinated? My opinion, no. However, knowing that I have that
pathway defect makes me more vigilant in staying tuned to what I was supposed to say tuned to. And then
you can help support that pathway with very specific nutrition to support that pathway. So again,
it gets back to that specificity based upon their genetics based upon other testing so that we can
be as in tuned to that person as possible and not have them on so many different things that
they just can't stay on. And then we look also at the tumor suppressor genes. Because your tumor
suppressor genes are what are supposed to kick on if that cell goes into replication. And if I have
defects on any specific tumor suppressor genes, then it's less likely to kick on and cause a
poptosis in that cell that's replicated. So it's important to look at those because there's very
specific nutrition that you could use to support that. Plus, that's a big piece of what gives us the
key to the diet of what can be feeding the cancer. So genetics are important. It's an important piece
of what we do for our practice. Please look at our website. Use it as a reference for different
things. Watch some of my videos if you can. And I do book cancer genes is not out yet, but that's
going to be a constantly changing book that's going to be all on video. And then my book cancer can't
kill you. I come from a very Christian perspective as you probably could tell. And I believe that if
we're surrendered to our Heavenly Father, then yes, we are supposed to deal with the things on this
Earth. Disease is one of them. But the most important thing is what we're going to do with
eternity. All right. Well, thank you for having me. I appreciate you. I will be out at the cancer
tutor booth and a little plug for them. We are a cancer tutor clinic that they research should
put us through this group need to be able to be a clinic for them. So check out their website.
There are wealth of information as well. So if you need to talk to me, I'll be out there for a
little bit. Thank you much.